the whole things I'm filling out because
she is this is quite an extreme
character presumably you get extreme
reactions from fans and things when you
when you meet people in the street yeah
I mean a lot of people just look at me
and think is it her but I had one
recently that was really strange someone
asked me for a photograph and I was like
yeah sure and was posing for a
photograph and then she quietly just
whispered in my ear will you strangle me
no but rebel your fans they love you I
would say sometimes love you too much
here's a picture of you with a fan there
on the tour so you know and because you
know he'd look good anyway you know with
her without tattoo he divine yeah I'm
not sure I'm not sure your face looks as
good here that's the back of somebody's
leg well go cuz that's the punchline
yeah I think that's the front obviously
we're not obvious
yeah I'm not really will have seen these
people okay this is a man and woman from
Poland yeah and what Bond's them is a
love of you
they've got matching what does it say
I'll make America eat again I wore it on
a hat you know now got it on their
bodies for life
[Music]
you